sometimes I wear jury sometimes I don't
sometimes I turned it to a rapper rapper
and I get my Slick Rick on and I want to
stack them but it's really heavy really
I be getting like neck pain
it was so worthless burger and I will
show you my jury collection yes I got
all my jury in this Louie Vuitton case I
take this jury box with me everywhere I
go and in fact even when I'm staying at
the hotels I'd still take this jury box
in the bag and I have my assistant carry
the bag just because like you know you
don't want to lose nothing like this
there's a lot of monument to pieces
inside it so I'm gonna start off with
this piece right here which is a rainbow
gradient designed by Karen Jules she
sent me a picture this was a double row
with the diamonds on the side and it
actually matches my ring and I got a
song called coach Cartier with like I'm
like Rainbow Shama or is rainbow so this
is like perfect that's a pretty penny I
like that rocky actually gave this to me
off his finger as rose gold and has like
all these different color sapphires in
it I wish it spent I could just go like
that that's the next one I remember
going to a Catholic school we had these
textbooks but I would look at like all
of these popes and they had like really
really nice jury like I don't know why
that stuck out to me as a child but I
remember seeing like all colored stones
all kind of stones and just look like
something out of a treasure chest so I
always said when I make some money or
when I'm able to get it I'll make some
custom pieces so that's what I do it's
not like a specific thing like diamonds
or rubies it's like whatever I'm feeling
at the time
[Music]
this right here is a chain that I got
from the blink says hood Pope it's the
same lettering as the tattoo I have with
my knees it says hope hope with my knees
well you hope hope is the traveler
traveler to hope hope and this is like
the first colorful piece that I have got
got me and I got the Hermes link it's a
beautiful piece I got my girls in the
Louboutin bag I'm not sure if you get a
rattle level it's a lot of girls in it I
lost a lot of grills I'm talking about
like thousands of dollars wrapped in
some hotel covers somewhere these are
the hope hope grows and its fangs it has
like pink sapphires Rubie on each side
and it has like the white diamonds in
the middle says hood the bottom says
Pope and these have the Ruby chocolate
diamonds on the side with pearls on each
side of the teeth and then I has like
the sapphires in the middle these was
inspired by that Pope that I seen with
the crucifix when I was a kid in
religion class this right here is a very
very sentimental piece to me this is the
first chain that actually got me making
money my dad when he passed away he got
this chain me we put it on him in his
casket so I was like I gotta get that
made over so I went and got it made over
this is the logo to forego he actually
created that logo I still use it to this
day
[Music]
this right here is the big boy this is
the yeah makini piece that I talked
about in the song playing Jane
Lamborghini for yams ASAP yams
this was his logo before he passed away
he was gonna start a record label yeah
my Guinea records so you're gonna have
yummy uni records in a sent worldwide it
says you [ __ ] with the bull you get the
horns and it has the Ferg logo the teeth
is baguettes
you know it's like bigger stones and I
at the eyes this is a Hermes link with
the diamonds in it I might just throw a
suit on and put the EMU Guinea piece on
you know Tupac style he had to angel the
definite day and that's where I was
inspired from that was like the blue
for this Jam bikini change this is a
vintage shake-up the jeweler's watch
this is the one that like jay-z was
wearing Pharrell puffy everybody was
wearing these watches back then as
dimers in the face if you look closely
you can see is four different times on a
gator ban yellow that's the Jacob watch
I always wonder one I never thought our
own one in fact I never thought that I
would actually get a chance to meet
Jacob himself and be good friends with
him which is he is my good friend so
this is what you call Canal Street jewel
and when I say Canal Street doesn't mean
it's not real go this is a really good
goal it's just that that's where I
happened to be at this is like the
anchor right here my Jesus came off it's
supposed to be like this but the Jesus
in the middle yeah I gotta get that
fixed oh this right here is the infamous
Plain Jane Rolex with the baguettes
inside this is my first like expensive
luxe watch that I've brought I went to
tour know and spend some money on this
I'll wear this when I'm with my grown
man [ __ ] I think like last year I got
this watch and I was gonna go crazy and
like get another one that was like all
white gold and I had like a piece of the
moon and it is something like that it
was like crazy like it's just crazy
James Bond looking tight rollers but I
said I'm a calm down everything is worth
a lot of money a kid save your money
less Derian and more savings